how's it go first my name is Pampa today
we are playing of Luna games yeah yeah
Luna games are five games of creepy my
little pony pasta they were supposed to
be pretty flying weird so let's check it
out
I love my little pony this is my
favorite game damn it I can double jump
oh well [ __ ] you then right all right
how do I
Bob bomb something iPad got it so creepy
shut up
he says Christ
I can't move my mouth so I delete damn
it come on this is so annoying
what do you want from me all therefore
well that sure was fun all right well
then let's play Luna 2 then I'm gonna
rewrite this [ __ ] hold shift to run
wow this future has gone so far I love
this game
who needs graphics when you have ponies
with little purple wings this is the
greatest game oh [ __ ] you Oh God why
would you do that
well I bet I just kill myself then [ __ ]
makes em fight the red I should have
[ __ ] my senpai yeah wings yourself now
ah there goes my hair bro watch him as
she goes
[Music]
now dammit not this [ __ ] again dammit
not this [ __ ] again quit
dammit why do you do this I'm gonna get
you Luna game alright from collecting
corrupted files doing virus scans we can
now move on to luma 3 this is so [ __ ]
stupid
why yes [ __ ] I think shaper hoes and
tricks I'm gonna [ __ ] games on your
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah look at me go
[ __ ] this is the best game in
the last
[Music]
oh it's get out yet it's getting dark
sound above 800 so going [ __ ]
fill it in my ass
something happened to music excited
named Stan [ __ ] you
what is this [ __ ] pony's man like
what are they wine moonwalk [ __ ] deader
than dead better than been better than
dune right one jump one jump I can do
this alright go
sorry Jesus what do you want from me
another Jam i fine you know what fine
really
what happened to her body she doesn't
look so sick away anymore
sorry your Sugoi I think guys is it our
I can use my computer now oh thank god
alright let's move on to Luna game for I
probably you can only play one time all
right Luna game for there we go I'm
excited for this my favorite part is of
these games are the music
so [ __ ] sweet really really come on
you met a terrible fate haven't you well
I'm playing this game I would say that's
that's a pretty terrible thing that
really what what what no it's getting
dark and run run you little pony [ __ ]
I'm not gonna die here I'm not gonna
I'll never die I bathed in Satan's blood
come on damn it
it's over okay you all right you know
what sure why why not so this is a white
hell it looks like um let's I don't know
is the scene that bad I kind of look
like an octopus oh god yeah man I'm
sorry you don't look like an octopus you
look like a fabulous princess just like
me just like me damn it
ah [ __ ] I mean even a thing called love
damnit [ __ ] what but don't hurt me
please don't hurt my computer I want I
needed to do my sorry okay you can have
my computer Teddy Edgar take care I
don't mean have I love you I'm kidding
dammit oh [ __ ] this games are crazy man
at least these last one don't break your
computer alright there's one more game
brothers one more then we did this [ __ ]
alright here we go
last Lou in the game we can do this bro
don't be scared oh god what that fudge
kick a hold shift to run space Power
Team track how does this play it's the
first day back in Kingdom so why don't
you suck my ass okay best game ever turn
hanger princess I'm sorry I can't really
talk right now I'm looking for my books
well sucks I need to stop saying that
[ __ ] I'm sorry
wow this game extra dies gameplay and
that's amazing I find her umbrella some
more [ __ ] don't be greedy damn it what
is happening what the [ __ ] is all this
[ __ ] 5050 we're not gonna collect 50
[ __ ] emeralds you kidding me got this
music just destroy my anus no [ __ ]
way
no no no no no where is a I regret
everything in life now
what the [ __ ] it oh god I've done
something terrible now have an I damn it
I took the black one that's what sorry I
have a condition doctors are trying to
figure out what is wrong with me I know
I get it alright now the ground just
disappeared
really [ __ ] matrix soundtrack
okay so it's book well
what oh you don't really I pinkie pie's
looking for we've got to get that [ __ ]
anyway alright what are you what's up
you can never have too many parties well
I guess she's right dad kill her that
would be great I would love to [ __ ]
murder her it's going to be so much fine
kill her now alright well give me a
knife or anything I don't I can't really
strangle her with my hooves you know
Pincess are you feeling okay
well that was wonderful
please best game ever ten out of ten bit
why cuz you're so full of [ __ ]
how about that it's that good enough for
you and that would